Speaker 1: Let's check in on the campaign of
Georgia Republican Senate candidate Herschel
Walker. If you said to me, David, sir, what is
the race that is depressing you the most this year
as Fetterman would be up there.
Kari Lake. Katie Hobbs would be up there. There's
some others that would be up there, but near or at
the top of the list has to be the Herschel Walker
story. Herschel Walker can barely speak and can't
explain his political positions and any kind
of detail on any issue. But most importantly,
he is now embroiled in multiple scandals in which
he is just straight up lying. He has been caught
urging and paying for multiple women to get
abortions despite claiming to be completely
against abortion. Abortion is murder, according to
him. No exceptions, no exceptions, no exceptions.
He's urged multiple women and paid for multiple
women to get abortions. He just denies it. He's
obviously lying. He has claimed multiple times to
be part of law enforcement and they're just lies.
He pulled out an honorary badge at a debate, was
laughed at and then keeps pulling the badge up.
He's a liar, liar, liar. And the new unbelievable
situation. Is that the second abortion accuser?
Has now given an interview on television. She
shows her face. She's being referred to as Jane
Doe. It's probably only a matter of time until the
woman is identified, but she's going by Jane Doe
but has shown her face. And she says that Herschel
Walker essentially gave her an ultimatum about the
abortion. You and the hypothetical child would not
be safe if you chose not to have this abortion.
Think of that. Listen to this from ABC News.
Speaker 4: He did not want me to have the child.
And he said that he said that because
of his wife's family and powerful people
around him, that I would not be safe
and that the child would not be safe.
That's very menacing. It is a very menacing. It
is very menacing now. And I felt threatened and I.
I thought I had no choice.
Speaker 1: Think about them.
Think about that. If that is true,
this guy is an absolute monster.
Now, there is, of course, the hypocrisy element to
this, which we're going to deal with in a moment.
But there is also the growing understanding
that this is not a nice guy. He's threatening
the woman he impregnated and the hypothetical
child with not being safe unless the woman gets
an abortion. His own son, Christian Walker, has
said that he and his mom had to move six times
due to the threats from Herschel Walker. There
is nothing here that actually is meeting the
self-described standard he puts on himself, which
is a great Christian man, a great father. All
these different. There's none of it whatsoever.
And even if you don't care about the specifics,
maybe you're a Georgia voter and you don't
care about the abortion issue. You care about
his view on taxes. I couldn't tell you what it
is, but you can understand it. Congratulations.
But don't you care about the fact that this guy is
a menace and a liar? Does that not matter at this
point in time? And the answer is, it very well may
not. And that's what we're going to look at next